when you're thinking of how you're gonna
approach research there are some really
good books Jane Mayer's written a good
book Barton Gellman running a good book
what do you look at and how do you
synthesize a story and come up with the
key facts that you want to focus on yeah
I mean that was really it one of the the
excite you know the exciting sort of
impetus of this movie that it was it was
a little bit like a detective novel or a
mystery going after it's and I
remembered reading in Dick Cheney's
autobiography at one point for some
reason he described the death of Fred
Hampton from the Black Panthers and he
just described it as Fred Hampton was
killed because Chicago police suspected
he had drugs and I was like oh it's
gonna be that kind of autobiography and
so we knew we had to go much deeper and
we had the luxury of just amazing
journalists some of them you name like
Jane Mayer also run Susskind tremendous
articles interviews that were out there
and it was all there I mean part of the
genius of Dick Cheney as he was using
the system to create this power so a lot
of it was there right in front of us
except of course the 22 million emails
and 500,000 documents he didn't hand
over which I would have loved to have
seen but otherwise do too and we
actually give it thanks at the end of
the credits due to the work of a lot of
great journalists we were able to find
it
deedy when you start work on this
production you're covering five decades
there are probably what a hundred and
some-odd
speaking parts a couple hundred
locations how do you start to figure out
the physical challenges of mounting a
production where you might just have
like five seconds of footage from
Cambodia of the bombing there well our
listen I think you have to start from a
place of genuinely feeling the privilege
of being able to tell a story which is
what I consider a producer's job and
when you have someone like Adam at the
helm and this extraordinary group of
people supporting you and expressing
what your intention
you just you just you just do it you
just figure out how to shoot all of this
movie in California and in a in a and
and you just all your job is to just
create space for everyone here to be
their best selves and to and to bring
their art and it's a privilege it's hard
but it's it's fun - I like crossword
puzzles it's a bit of like a puzzle
speaking of crossword puzzles I want to
ask about editorial Hank and about a
couple of scenes the Shakespeare in bed
scene and about how that came together
how you checked it with audiences and I
also have to ask about the dance
sequence that's not in this film and
about how that was checked with
audiences and what do you learn as
you're cutting and testing a film about
what the audience is willing to embrace
you know this film was every film every
film you work on as it seems says has a
certain hallmark and and with this film
the hallmark was one of letting go you
know we had a spectacular a spectacular
dancing we which is not in the film we
had just a truly beautiful prologue
where you don't we said we set young
dick and Lynn up in Wyoming and that's
not in the film you know so when we
school the way the way Adams always
worked if I if I can speak for you
because he he's he's so strongly into
improv he detests the film so we
screened the film how many times 10 11
times many times many times yes just to
get the temperature not it isn't that we
wanted to hear what other people said so
much as we wanted to feel how an
audience was feeling you know and what
we found
that the audience was feeling was that
they found that the dancing was kind of
repellent they just you know it in and
of itself it was beautiful but as part
of the flow it did it stopped the film
well we kept joking throughout the
process like Dick Cheney did not want
anyone to make a movie about his life I
mean everything he did was design people
that dance and he certainly didn't want
that and so we kept Hank and I in that
edit room kept felt like we you know we
felt like we were chasing down a shadow
the entire time and this guy not only
didn't leave breadcrumbs there's no path
there's no forest there's a Dunkin
Donuts where the forest should be
alright I went too far with the metaphor
I apologize but but honestly this guy
does not want his story told he was very
smart he knew that power does not reside
necessarily in the spotlight and he gave
us he gave us a run for our money but
that was also what was so exciting about
it was every screening every day we'd
have in the Edit room we were chasing
this guy down and we were learning every
time and when we when we finally got rid
of some of these scenes that we loved we
found that the Shakespeare started to
sing that really worked and it became
part of the center of the film Steve I'm
gonna ask you about rummy and about how
you approached him we have kind of the
public persona that I think a lot of
people are familiar with but then we
have the private person we see in the
film what does that give you as an actor
in terms of license and what Adam wanted
out of the way we see Rumsfeld when he's
not on camera I'm not at liberty to talk
about
he's a that's how that's part of how I
approached it because I figured this guy
was very different in private and that's
kind of where the imagination comes in
because you can't be sure who that
person is in private you get a pretty
good glimpse about what he's like in the
public eye but but that that other side
to him is a little bit more of an
invention I think and the public part I
always thought of him as a very kindly
uncle when I would see him in press
conferences he's very sweet and affable
and I think the insidiousness of what
lies on the other side is kind of fun
but at the same time you know I I
certainly didn't approach him like he
was a villain in any way and he
certainly didn't think he was I don't
think villains I think you know but
there's if I can just say some no no you
go legally Hank you're not allowed to
speak right now it's a really cool thing
this is how it's been for the past year
there's a lot of pathos in the
performance and and well that's my magic
I thought that was my magic it is your
magic um no and I think that's the other
side of it too that you know there these
are all human beings they're not you
know you can look at them as these
figure heads and you can look at them as
public personas but ultimately they they
have feelings and and certainly this
this guy had a bit of a downfall and you
kind of imagine where he would be in
that moment
Amy this is a movie that's very much
about a marriage and it's about a
relationship and it's about how
important Lynne is to dick and what she
meant to him and how she really put him
on his way and I'm wondering when you're
thinking about ways to approach Lynne
she's written a lot of books she's
written a memoir blue skies no fences
what was important to you about Lynne
and how did you become an advocate for
her in the film I mean I didn't really
know a lot about Lynne going into it I
didn't know anything personally about
her I knew a little bit about sort of
her curated self you know the self that
she presented but for me we was starting
with her memoir going back and hearing
because she's it's it's not like dicks
at all she talks in great detail about
things but she talks about it in a way
that feels almost romantic like sort of
I don't know if anyone's read her memoir
it's very interesting it's worth a read
but that's sort of where I started to
understand her ambition and focus that
she's had it since she was a young girl
this was something that sort of was bred
into her from her ancestors and through
tough times you know so that's kind of
where I started as I I really started to
recognize that girl more than the woman
that I saw in the interviews now I
recognized the girl that I was reading
about in the book so I started with that
girl and I just built upon that
Christian there's obviously a physical
transformation that takes place for you
as an actor I'm interested in the
internal transformation about
understanding the intellect the
psychology the way that Chaney saw the
world
does that happen in parallel with the
physical transformation which one comes
first and how did you get to that
internal transformation to play Dick
Cheney
I've got no technique at all and I don't
really know what comes first it all sort
of starts happening at the same yeah I
don't really know and honestly I
definitely you know there's certain
physical things that you feel that and
then you go alright now that's gonna
help clue into there but I just wing it
with each and every each and every day
and Amy talking about the younger Lynne
you know there's I find this movie so
poignant and moving and I get very
emotional watching this and I find it
hilarious as well and and I truly think
it's one of the most remarkable films
I've ever seen in my life it affects me
in a way that I I was so surprised even
having you know been there when we were
making it but and part of that is to do
with a very much always imagined dick in
trying to get into his psychology you
know before he met Lynn he really
admired Jedediah Smith and John Coulter
and Hugh glass and all of that and had
this very adventurous you know streak
and this idea of what it meant to be a
man and then and then you know the
incremental changes and Hank in and
what's-his-name at the end and he had
something to do with the film Hank and
Adam I just adore that little short film
I was just trying to hardly tell Hank in
the wings where he's where dick is
staring in at the Oval Office and he's
now and there's there's obviously still
that lust but there's a sense of arrival
an incredible power and the silhouette
and then that just the mac and cheese
conversation with this young family you
know
but it always brings tears to my eyes
that because of just the small
adjustments that people make in their
lives and you know and then you suddenly
become this silhouette staring in at the
Oval Office and just so I did my part as
we were filming but I can't tell you how
much happened in the Edit room there
just how stunned I am with with what you
guys managed in there on top of you know
getting to work with Amy and Steve and
Sam and everybody else and what clearly
was really special on the dais you know
Hank and I'm just took it to a whole
different place
Adam TD Hank Steve Amy Christian thank
you so much for coming